julian sitzt auf der wiese in der sonne
das ist imani sie geht jetzt zur
vorlesung julian sieht imani er findet
sie schön
juli an steht auf und rennt ihr nach
julian will mit imani flirten aber sie
will das nicht schon und carla sind ein
paar
sie halten händchen und gehen spazieren
da kommt darian darian sieht schorn und
carla ist adrian sauer
was ist hier passiert darian hat am
samstagabend carla geküsst
er wusste nicht dass sie einen freund
hat jetzt erfährt schon dass carla ihn
betrogen hat
carla ist überrascht
sie hatte daran hier nicht erwartet
shawn ist super angepasst
er hätte nicht gedacht dass carla ihn
betrügt schauen und serien sind sauer
aber sie möchten nicht streiten
also gehen sie beide und verlassen carla
carla geht weg aber wer ist das
das sind jackie und francisco
sie sind seit zwei jahren zusammen
francisco hat jackie zur bücherei
gebracht aber warum
hier haben sich von cisco und jackie vor
zwei jahren kennengelernt
aber was macht francisco jetzt er macht
jack ihm einen heiratsantrag
sie hat ja gesagt
[Musik]